speaking of youtube dramas and people
that are worried about losing their
business what's your thoughts on ethan
klein's recent spat with john peterson
i think that what we're witnessing is
the
inevitable radicalization of ethan klein
because of his twitter usage uh ethan
obviously used to be a sort of
anti-social justice commentator he used
to mock all of this and little by little
and i think it's because of the
natural environment of twitter having
purged so many conservatives and
suppressing
conservative viewpoints
that essentially just makes it seem like
the the only
and
most sensible and common viewpoint is
that of the far left i mean it's written
in twitter's terms of service you can't
misgender people and things like this
and there are so many the the political
environment is so skewed on the platform
that it becomes a sort of water in which
you swim and
i don't think ethan klein is the
smartest person in the world and so i
don't think he recognizes that and i
mean
take for example the way that he
disavowed jordan peterson he was like
you
did something transphobic you said
something you this you said that and
essentially it was just a list of crimes
against progressivism but i mean that's
the same as an imam coming to me and
saying well you've eaten bacon you've
had you've drunk alcohol you've
fornicated before marriage i'm like okay
i'm not muslim you know these are not my
standards i don't i don't agree that
these are things i should care about and
ethan klein has adopted them
unthinkingly because other people on
twitter these are these are the things
that the big twitter you know viral
twitter threads and tweets um
highlight and so it's put it into his
mind that these are important things but
are they important things or is there
something more important in ethan's life
like his wife and children perhaps you
know rather than a very tiny fringe
minority of which he probably knows very
few people
but this is this is the thing this is
the problem with twitter and so
and you can see this this dramatic
leftward shift in his content and now
he's hosting
a podcast with a guy called hassan [ __ ]
for anyone who doesn't know he's uh he's
a literal communist and the kind of
communist that one would call a tanki
uh he he he thinks the soviet union was
a good idea and that america deserved
911.
uh and so
he he explicitly said america is at 911
yes
he had to go on he's the nephew of
genkuger of the young turks and he was
working at the young turks at the time
it's a couple of years ago and he had to
go on the young turks and with his uncle
and essentially
be told he had to disavow this position
he can't say that america deserved 911.
and the thing is he refused to do so and
now he's no longer at the young turks
because even jank who obviously hates
america himself was like look we can't
just say that you know you can't just
say you know we're americans we're in
america we're not going to say that
america deserves the worst terror attack
has ever experienced uh but hassan for
some reason thinks the isis position is
uh the the jihadi position is more
legitimate than the american position
ethan's got him on a podcast now yeah
it's called leftovers which is a really
stupid name but then they're not very
bright people but the the interesting
thing about this is that hassan looks
like the smart guy next to ethan
but the best parts though the best part
even though he's a literal communist
nathan is basically a communist now
himself
the best part about it is their
phenomenal success
their set costs three million dollars
and in the middle like
between the segments of their thing i
watched an episode of it and they they
have to do like three adverts of uh you
know for buy this product and you'll
grow
i don't know some sort of
anti-capitalist chest hair or whatever
it is they sell but it's the most
hyper capitalist thing in the world and
you can see during the shilling hassan's
face he just looks like he's dying
inside his sight
this just doesn't
work you've got to pay for it all gotta
gotta pay for that three million dollar
mansion that he lives in and uh so by
promoting communism they're literally
being as capitalist as possible and
dying in on the inside and i i kind of
love to watch it i kind of love because
i've i've never done a shill i've never
promoted a product i've never
had any kind of corporate contract or
anything like that and i do anything i
do i do on a gentleman's agreement
because i think that's
there's something important there right
because it's about not just you are
going to be forced to keep your word but
it's about the desire to keep your word
it shows good will and good faith in
what you do
and so that i think
there's something there but um
but the fact that i've never had to do
the shill and i'm pro-capitalism and
these communists who are constantly
raging about lake state's capitalism are
the ones shilling
shilling their hearts out
it's there's just a beautiful irony so
is ethan are you thinking that ethan's
sort of been passively peered pressured
in just based on what he sees on twitter
i don't think it's peer pressure i just
think that ethan is not really a very
philosophically minded guy and these
people the the the ideology itself and
the people who are the authors of the
main strains of thought within the
ideology are very very smart and what
they've done for the last 50 60 years
probably since since uh the
since post-war uh europe the time of
post-war europe um they've
established that look
the way the things that work in the
united states
is not going to bring about communism
and therefore we need to undermine this
and deliberately engage in what uh
communist antonio gramsci called a war
of position so we can see that the
society is a very powerful society it's
not going to be overthrown in a
revolution like lenin did against the
provisional government
and so what what they need to do is wear
away the society in order to open up the
possibility of going towards communism
and so for the past i mean
probably
probably nearly 100 years now that
they've been creating memes right
they've been working on ways of
cracking open the contradictions or the
um inconsistencies within our philosophy
as the sort of like classically liberal
enlightenment west and
trying to break it apart slowly but
surely just as if you know you've got
this you've seen the you've seen the um
the videos the viral videos you've seen
on facebook of like some guy in india or
something he's got this giant stone and
he's got like just a couple of
metal um
uh chisels and and a hammer and he puts
a couple of them in and then crack the
whole thing splits open right it's that
kind of effect that they're going for
they're like right there's a there's a
contradiction here there's an
inconsistency here there's something
that's just not filled out here if we
just hammer on these bits hard enough
the whole thing starts breaking apart
and that's what they've been doing to us
and they've been doing it very
consciously they know that they're doing
this and they want to do it because
frankly they think that communism is
where we should all be even though
there's never been a good example of
communism and never will be um but it's
it's kind of like the unfinished puzzle
of the enlightenment you know the smart
people look at it and think i can solve
this this will fix all of our problems
but it's nonsense um
but yeah so ethan is essentially um the
victim of that process i was going to
say because i'm always skeptical about
the people that are whatever
at the coal face of this
i'm so non-conspiratorial with the way
that i think but the fact that ethan
klein could be co-opted into some grand
attempt to try and take down the west
just doesn't seem realistic but
it what it seems like what you're saying
is that he's sort of a
a willing
ignorant participant like a useful idiot
the problem is uh it's not a conspiracy
um it's all out in the open and i can
just tell you the names of the people
who are doing it and the books in fact
in fact do i have one on my desk yeah
here we go
so
i mean it begins with people like the
frankfurt school which theodore dorno
hawkheimer marcusa and a bunch of others
um this is dialects of enlightenment
where they're literally trying to figure
out what's gone wrong why haven't we
achieved communism why is capitalism one
and then this this is what's called
critical theory this moves into
uh what we now know as critical race
theory and then that's people that
begins with people like derek bell um
let me let me get off my uh my notes
actually because right so you've got
derek bell you've got alan friedman
you've got richard delgado murray
matsuda um obviously kimberly crenshaw
harland dalton anthony cook you can look
all of these people up i don't have the
book with me it's at work you know it's
in the office otherwise i'd be able to
bring up that huge book it's just called
critical race theory the key writings of
former movement it was edited and
curated by kimberly crenshaw and she's
got a bunch of s's in here and but a
bunch of the essays that she's written
uh
in harvard law school this was uh back
in 1987 and 1989 i think it was uh that
um she expressly says this but uh i mean
and in
various other writings of critical race
theory you can find this for example
she's got an essay called race reform
and retrenchment transformation
legitimation and anti-discrimination law
and this is where she says and i quote
she wants gramski to literally uh she
wants to use the grand scheme tactics to
begin withering away our society uh and
therefore she says she wants to adopt a
legal she the problem is that a legal
strategy will not include redistribution
redistribution of wealth right that's
what she thinks and so you can see
exactly it is a she's a communist she is
interested in achieving communism and
she is a in the legal
arena the illegal academia and she can't
get the redistribution of wealth that
she's looking for for through american
law because american law is of course
based on classical liberalism which is
fundamentally based on the right to own
property communism of course is that
nobody owns property so this is never
going to happen there's no justification
for it and so what she does is realize
well if we can essentially expand the
definition of the words because one of
the things she points out is that look
if i just come in and say right we need
a revolution then all of the all of the
the systems that are just carrying along
happily and she tries to put that down
there's going to bash her out of the way
it's like we're not having a revolution
get out of here you know we've got a
constitution for example but then she
realized what we need to do and she says
literally
it she says this quote demands for
change that do not reflect the
institutional logic will probably be
ineffective which is true and this is
the demand for revolution not gonna work
and so what she does essentially slides
into the institutional logic and expands
the definition of the words that they're
using
in order to encompass their antonym now
for example she in this particular essay
uses the example of racism racism she
she gives two definitions the expansive
and restrictive views of racism
what who can sense to this who agrees
that there are two definitions of racism
i don't agree with that racism in my
opinion is the conscious act of
discriminating against someone because
of their race because you do not like
their race but that's not her definition
her definition is an outcome that has a
that can be categorized based on races
that shows some kind of difference
i don't agree that's racism but if she
redefines it to be that and then
proliferates this view of what racism is
which is now a systemic structural
everything around us is complicit in
the average white family having more
wealth than the average black family
then suddenly our entire society becomes
racist and now you can see how the
critical race theorists are saying well
we live in a giant racist society it's
okay but you can never point to an act
of racial discrimination but they don't
care
sorry they don't need to because they've
concept creeped it and expanded it out
yes precisely so is it is it the case
with jordan is he
tainting
the purity of ethan when you look at his
back catalogue
yes uh without a doubt
um
and notice how this came unprovoked from
ethan klein as well right so just to
just to quickly finish this all
basically ethan has found himself just
it's he's in this river right that's
been redirected to the critical race
theory view of things the work view
things uh sorry i've got a massive spot
there because the other day i was
reading something i had a spot and i
just kept scratching it and it looks
gross
and i'm trying not to scratch it now um
ethan ethan is is just in the river of
wokeness wokeness is critical race
theory that's what it all comes from and
again kimberly crenshaw is basically the
chief strategist of this because in her
essays she was writing well look it's
not just uh we can do this for black
people and black women and she coined
the term in sectionality because she was
writing an essay about the intersection
of how
the the way that american civil rights
work at the time this is back in the 90s
or the 80s uh is that they would
recognize oppression because you're a
black or because you're a woman but they
didn't insect into black women and if
you think about it this was inevitable
that this would come about you know if
you if you envision envisage the world
that you know blacks are oppressed or
women are oppressed uh then why couldn't
you have black women being oppressed you
know doubly oppressed you know there's
no reason that this logic wasn't going
to come about at some point and kimberly
crenshaw was the first one to identify
calling the term in sexuality and from
this she even says well we can do this
with the gay community with the trans
community and this is back in the 80s
and 90s she's saying this so you can see
how long these ideas have been on the
pot for on the boil right and it's just
it's not just her of course is dozens
and dozens of different
left-wing academics communist academics
because they're looking to destroy this
what they call the patriarchy the the
inherited structures of classical
liberal society in the west because
these are the things as gramski says are
preventing the communist revolution and
they're not wrong like they're not wrong
that the fact that we've got families
and business owners and properties and
governments and rules and laws yeah
these are all preventing a communist
revolution that's true that's why we
have them we don't want a communist
revolution we want a prosperous society
where we can feel safe and secure and we
know what's going to happen tomorrow and
we've you know i'm going to wake up my
car's going to be in the driveway and
things like this because i only you know
that's much more preferable than no one
owning anything and the state having
total domination over everything we have
uh which is even not even the end of
what they're aiming for in communism but
the point is
this is the entire basis of woke
philosophy and
ethan is the victim of the memes that
the memetic warfare they've been
engaging in so what they're doing is
saying well look trans rights ethan he's
like well i mean they're human beings of
course they have rights you know
everyone has rights but what's a trans
right why would you bring that up why
wouldn't you just say human right it's
exactly it should be exactly the same
thing should it not except the trans
right is something new now you know it's
something
different there are apparently rights
that trans people have that i don't have
for example
which is implicit in the construction of
the phrase trans rights anything you
know being a bumbling idiot he's just
like well of course i don't know
of course i believe in this but once you
start going he's putting like a foot in
the river you know and then oh you know
affirmations and people retweeting and
and the general sort of radicalizing
effect of twitter getting in bed with
other leftists who then take him down
the sort of mimetic
paths that they
bring you on uh and
now he's like
and he noticed that he just comes out
and just out of nowhere no one was
saying you know ethan you have to
disavow jordan peace and no one's saying
this this is an old interview but he
just came out i was like i'm going to
take down that jordan peterson
interviews like
okay no one's making you do that ethan
but you've chosen to do it because
you've accepted a series of premises
that have led you to the conclusion that
actually you used to be a terrible
person and it's like that's weird
because it leaks to me and all the world
like you're the terrible person now like
ethan used to do decent things he used
to actually help people he used to he
used to do a bit of investigative
journalism occasionally and he used to
entertain people and just you know
be an entertainer he wasn't the active
piece of [ __ ] that he has become like
you can see this in his
like betrayal and deception of stephen
crowder it was just a scummy thing to do
absolutely scummy and the way he's going
after joe rogan the way he's gonna have
john pizza and people that i would
consider to be people of high moral
character you know people i've both met
i've had conversations with them they
did not seem in any way deceptive they
seem to exhibit virtue in their daily
lives they have millions of adoring fans
because of their virtues and you've got
this fat communist idiots going they're
bad people
shut up ethan you're the useful idiot of
a bunch of people who are trying to
overthrow the west frankly what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace